hello friends this week I'm very happy
to say that we are going to learn how to
learn Peter C Brown is the co-author of
make it stick that book is about
seminars you can get in the world of
learning to learn no matter what your
area of pursuit in life it's pretty
likely that being able to expedite your
capacity to intake information and then
recall it at will is probably gonna be
pretty useful and that doesn't matter if
it's learning a new subject or learning
a new physical skill if it's knitting or
archery or law all of them require you
to be able to remember and recall what
it is that you're trying to learn and
Peter manages to lay out a really good
framework for doing that today in other
news the modern wisdom YouTube channel
has now crossed a thousand subscribers
and has nearly hit two million watch
minutes which is pretty crazy in the
first two months of it being up so if
you haven't already please head to
youtube search modern wisdom podcast and
give it a subscribe it would be a
massive help also if you haven't already
whatever platform you're on whether it's
tune in fm
I'm not even sure if that's a podcast
listening platform we are everywhere
Spotify iTunes stitcher wherever you're
listening please try and give us a five
star rating I don't really know if it
helps but it strokes the ego a little
bit so do if you can but now we're gonna
learn how to learn Peter Brown bring it
on
[Music]
mr. Peter Brown welcome to modern wisdom
Thank You Chris it's great to be here
how are you today I'm doing just dandy
it's a middle of summer here in
Minnesota
it's nice time to be here lovely I've
recently recently returned from the
states and the the weather was fantastic
but apparently I've missed the one warm
week that we get in the UK as well
I love the white so I should have
doubled that I should have doubled down
and just stayed home I guess I
understand so I want to get straight
into it
can you define to me what learning means
yes
for me I define learning is picking up
knowledge or skill that resides in your
memory and is available to you when you
need it later to solve a problem or take
advantage of an opportunity ok that
sounds like a very a very curated
definition was that something that you
came upon easily or is that something
that you had to develop through a lot of
a lot of thinking a lot of conceptual
deconstruction yeah I just made it up
but it's because I made it up when I
started working on writing the book make
it stick because I felt that I owed the
reader a definition of what we're
talking about with learning and I
figured well I'll just try that and see
if it holds up and it held up fine
was there a satisfactory definition in
advance of that no I'm sorry but I might
have a problem with my headphones
because that kind of comes on and off oh
ok I'm not too sure what's going on
there that might be that might be on my
side
ok so ask the question again was there
an existing definition of learning that
you were happy with or was that one that
you just created did that need to be
there as far as you were concerned
I felt it needed I felt we needed we
owed the reader a definition of writing
a book about learning we owed the reader
a definition of what learning is and so
I sort of thought about a little bit and
I wrote that and I thought we'll start
with that and see if it holds up as we
go through the book and and it held up
fine some people in science the sciences
refer to learning as three things one
being in encoding which is when you
first encounter material and it's it's
encoded as traces in the hippocampus
consolidation this is the process by
which it moves it migrates over hours or
days into other parts of the brain where
long-term memories are stored in
retrieval being able to recall it again
later so the scientists think of it as
that's learning for them for me it's you
you learn it and you remember it and you
can recall it when you need it
I understand so can you give us a little
bit of background to the book make it
stick and why you were compelled to
write that yeah sure I've been retired
for some years I made my living as
marketing and planning consultant to
corporations here in Minnesota and I had
turned to writing books and I was
between book projects now sitting down
with my brother-in-law Henry wrote agur
Henry wrote a girl who goes by Roddy is
internationally preeminent in the field
of memory and learning he's a cognitive
psychologist and he was telling me that
he was just coming to the end of a ten
year study of what strategies lead to
better retention of the new material and
he had a team of a cognitive
psychologist at 11 different
universities doing this work with their
their doctoral students and postdocs and
over a decade of such studies they were
coming to some findings that were
counterintuitive and he said I've been
trying to figure out how to get this out
to a broader general audience
maybe we should collaborate on a book
so that's how I got into it I'm not a
scientist but I was very taken by what
they were finding so Roddy Henry wrote
agar and one of his colleagues mark
McDaniel was also a cognitive
psychologist they're both at Washington
University in st. Louis Missouri the two
of them and I collaborated on this book
okay so I guess you've got the you've
got the cognitive firepower in there on
those guys's sides you know 10 years and
11 facilities that have been used for
that particular study it's not as if
you're it's not as if you short of of
research on that side No
and the book is based on decades of
research and reaches far beyond the work
of that team but you're right that it's
it's firmly grounded in the empirical
evidence but I tried to write a book
that was highly anecdotal and engaging
to read so that people would stick with
it and we could tell stories that
Illustrated what the science shows about
how learning works well that gave it a
different kind of twist than the than
the typical scientific study publication
yeah for sure I think in order to get
the wider population to be able to buy
into books like these you need to bring
it back down to earth there needs to be
some tacit examples and some things that
people can relate to everyday life
talking about standard deviations away
from the norm and you know it doesn't
like it doesn't like anyone's eyes it'll
light some people's eyes apart your two
co-authors would be it would get would
get turned on by that but I guess for
the for the normal reader that's not
going to be that's not exactly gonna
like light the fire in their valley so
to speak I wouldn't keep me up at night
it put on your right to sleep yeah
agreed
agreed so you've got the existing
research there did you think that
writing a book on the science of
learning was was important to to publish
to
it's a wider wider audience well I
thought so and they did too and I think
the reason it struck home with me is
because I have a bachelor's degree from
college I brought us I don't have a
graduate degree you know higher training
I've always been someone who's taken an
interest in things and then gone about
learning about them and figuring them
out and what their research showed is
that the way a lot of people
particularly students go about learning
is by review when we're reading and
trying to push stuff another brain but
what is far more effective is trying to
get it out of the brain it's the
tinkering the trial and error the
experimentation the learning from the
turns and setbacks that you get and I
just felt very much personally affirmed
by what the research showed and I
thought I would really enjoy getting my
hands on this and because I felt it was
very important but I also felt I was
really interesting well it's superbly
fundamental isn't it that no matter what
discipline it is that you're studying in
that the science of learning to learn is
foundationally ahead of all of the
things ahead of everything that you're
trying to do you need to be able to know
how to learn because it's it's universal
right it's ubiquitous it is and from the
moment we leave the womb children are
experimenting touching tasting trying
things and when we get older we lose
some of that and I think the traditions
of our schools are such that learning
involves an expert who imparts knowledge
to students and in fact it doesn't
really it's not really very effective
I think athletes know this when they go
out on the field and they have a coach
the athlete knows that she or he has to
figure this out and the coach can give
feedback and they could work at it but
most students including athletes who
walk into a classroom expect the
learning to be aparted to them and and
learning is not imparted learning is
something that's really acquired unless
you know extraordinary circumstances
were you you have some tremendously
significant emotionally significant
events of things that we're trying to
build in the way of mental understanding
and mental models and mastery you have
to acquire that's interesting so did you
have a look at or can you give us some
of the typical approaches of an
unlearned learner as I as I'm gonna call
call someone someone who's unenlightened
as to perhaps what is what the research
suggests did you have a look at what's
the typical approach well that well in
surveying students college students that
by far and away the major study
strategies are rereading material
underlining and highlighting and
note-taking that kind of thing but the
science shows that what's far more
effective after you've heard a lecture
or read a passages to turn aside and
give yourself a little quiz what were
the big ideas in this material try to
recall it and try to say to yourself
this relates to what I already know in
the following ways or if I were to put
this in my own words here's how I would
do it it's engaging the mind in the
material so I I summarized all of make
it stick with three ideas the first one
is the one I've just described learning
happens when you struggle to get the
learning out and apply it not when you
continue to reexpose yourself to it it's
about getting it out
a second big idea for me is we try to
make learning simple for students but
actually there are some kinds of
difficulties that are desirable an
example of a couple one would be when
you practice a a motor skill like your
golf putt or you practice something
you're learning like solving
mathematical problems it's good to
practice a little lot of them space it
out and come back to it at a later time
but at a later time takes more effort to
recall what was the formula and how to
successfully apply it and it that kind
of spaced practice feels like you're not
getting it because your performance is
rough but the actual effort involved in
recalling that new material from your
long-term memory
strengthens the connections - it helps
it reconsolidate helps bring forward the
most important points and it makes it
easier recall again later so spacing out
your practice is better than practicing
things in a masked fashion that's a
desirable difficulty it doesn't feel
good it definitely doesn't know another
desirable difficulty is mixing the
practice of similar problem types so if
you're let's take the bath the math
example if you're practicing learning
how to find the volume of a cube and a
wedge and some other kind of series of
different solids the typical way that
you would do that with a math book was
you you just look at eight different
wedges and you'd apply the formula eight
times and then you'd move on and do
these other different kinds of solids
and during practice you do very well
you've got tests that you do about
ninety percent but if in fact once
you've learned each of the formulas your
practice problems were in random
sequence you would only do about 50
percent right and you wouldn't feel too
good about that but a week later you
will have remembered that same 50
percent you would
do extremely well on a test compared to
the others who have gone from ninety
percent down to 23 percent because they
didn't mix it up and when you get a test
where it's mixed up they can't remember
which formula went with which problem
yes so this whole notion of mixing your
practice which does not feel good is
very powerful for improving your ability
to recognize the kind of problem you're
facing and picking the kind of solution
that's going to be correct
that's interesting so there are other
kinds of desirable difficulties and so
the notion of if it's clear as a bell
I'm sure I'll remember it you know it's
not really true if you have to reconcile
different ideas between the lecture and
the book chapter or what have you that
mental effort is what's going to make it
stick that's interesting is the second
big idea that some did some difficulties
are desirably okay I'm the third number
three number three is that our intuition
leads us astray
so our intuition is when I reread it
many times I get very fluent in it I'm
on top of it I can do that can do that
and take a test the next morning I pull
an all-nighter and I can get a great
grade on the test it doesn't stick
though what happens if you're tested
again a week later you've lost about a
half of it our intuition says if we
practice our 20 foot putt over and over
again we see improvement and it's true
you do but that improvement leans not
short to remember it but the skills have
not been consolidated in long-term
memory that takes overnight or it takes
days so you walk off the golf course
thinking you've really done a service to
yourself on your 20 foot putt but much
better would be to do a few 20 foot
putts then do other strokes and then
come back and mix it up and it doesn't
feel you don't see that same kind of
improvement but your brain is getting
better at judging distances and the
motor skills required you know to to
make a good stroke
so our intuition leads us astray and it
causes us to spend time in strategies
that are not paying us back okay so I
mean that's a to me conceptually make
sense but it's quite a probably quite a
big departure away from anecdotally what
I would have thought good learning
should be done you know the kind of the
force it down your throat so to speak
I'm sure you know the the the really
drill it into you stick to one task for
a long time I know if you if you listen
to the podcast that I did with dr. you
and Lawson we discuss in that about
multitasking and the Pomodoro Technique
deep work and trying to focus wholly on
one task it's not too far of a jump to
think that instead of just focusing on
revision you should drill that down
again to just focusing on one topic
within your revision right and I think
that that could quite erroneous yeah
erroneously be one step too far in terms
of the house of specific your being with
your agent with your revision time so
let's go from the start can you explain
how learning and memory or learning and
recall relate to each other
yeah sure our memory has two components
actually my co-author Roddy rota ger is
his field is memory and he's really
written the break a lot of the
breakthrough material on memory
including uh
discovering this whole field of false
memory but in any case long-term memory
is is in different parts of the brain
than short-term memory so when we're
talking about short-term memory or
working memory it's the list you go to
the grocery store you maybe remember it
long enough to pick up the things and
then maybe you might or might not
remember you need to stop by the dry
cleaner on the way home but that's gone
is there a is there a time if they're a
approximate time limit usually on that
24 hours or not particularly but III
don't I don't think so I think it
depends on whether you're trying if
you're making an effort to remember it
for longer for example you're you rent a
bike and it's got a four-digit
combination lock and you're trying to
remember those four digits when you can
give yourself a tool to do that I was
with a friend and in Adelaide Australia
and she said I can't I can't even
remember my pin number on my card how am
I gonna do this with my bike well what
are the numbers she said it's five to
six eight no no I said well I'll break
it into 52 and 68 what can you do with
that all 52 is easy that's the cards in
a deck of cards in 68 oh that's the
swirly girly she said so she still
remembers this four-digit number of
years later so there aren't devices you
can use you know well if I have
information to keep to keep in your mind
so but the long-term memory is different
from short-term memory and that is it
needs to migrate to another part of the
brain and be connected to the other
things that you know so the two aspects
of long-term memory are one that it gets
thoroughly and embedded in the brain and
connected to many different points of
knowledge if you can attach a visual
image like us medical schools to annales
talking to who was trying to remember
stuff medical stuff and he said I
realized after reading the research that
if I paused and made a mental picture of
the the organ I was reading about and
thought about its connections that I
could remember that whole thing better
what you get more different connections
in the brain which become routes to
finding it again later and recalling it
so it's partly about having having it
thoroughly embedded in your brain and
it's partly about having the cues you
need to find it later when you want it a
lot of things that we've learned in life
we can't recall because we've reassigned
the cues to other things in the meantime
in terms of what you saw to use well
what I mean Chris is when you come to LA
and you rent a car you have to create no
queues to remember to stay on the right
side of the road
the queues if you are going to take your
a-levels for example in psychology as
was the case of a psychology professor
at Oxford that we talked to
he took his students his students were
have mastered the content but the
pressure and the a-levels you don't know
which materials are gonna be asked to
write and then in each of the ones
you're asked to write there's you know
multiple paragraphs I'm sure you know
this better than I but yes so he took
his students to coffee shops and he'd
say ok and I'm imagine that you've what
you're walking into the coffee shop and
you're going around the perimeter of the
shop and they will attach meaning to the
different parts of the furnishings with
the layout that give them cues a name of
something that cue that next paragraph
in there right up so when they learn
what the subject is they have to write
about they say ok that was at the
such-and-such
you know pastry shop yeah and I was
sitting there and I can see I came in oh
yeah I called that fern you know
something or other and they and on they
can go they have the queues so under
pressure when we tend to kind of freeze
up in being able to recall material
that's a cert of mnemonic device yeah
those are accused by which you can bring
it up it's the it's the beginning of the
deck of cards that starts to tumble into
the rest of the knowledge right exactly
so I can certainly draw a parallel
between that and my learning style so to
give you a little bit of a little bit of
context for myself my learning style
from probably my GCSEs of 15 and 16 was
to write summarise notes and to then
completely verbatim record in my mind
what the notes were on the page so I
would know that top left starting at the
top it was this particular bit than this
then I could see when I got into the
exam I could actually feel in my mind
where let's say that I'd written a word
incorrectly and I'd crossed it out I'd
be like ok so it's three pages in it's
that old is that there's the word that's
written correctly
and those sort of hues I'm aware that
that you know had I have had I've been
able to read your book before I went to
university I'd have probably had
probably had a much easier time of it
but it was kind of for me I guess I was
I was I was using recall but that was
blunt force like just complete yet
source verbatim great and that wasn't
using the desirable difficulties spacing
and that also wasn't using point number
three either so you know I think I'd
maybe I'd maybe focused on the recall
and I was I discovered myself that using
recall was a good way for me to at least
wait
it's pointless learning something if you
then can't if you can't then pull it
back out as you say you know it's almost
as if what happened either yeah is
pointless and so we had an email from
someone recently he would read the book
and said I'm you know I've developed a
new way of taking notes and I'd like to
know what you think of it he said
instead of trying to capture everything
that the lecturer tells me I've read the
material and I hear the lecture I start
have been writing questions in each area
so that when I go back to review my
notes I'm actually requiring myself to
recall from memory and look up if I
can't recall it what the material is
yeah that's pretty kind of you know
that's a clever way of doing it because
that's what you're gonna have to do a
test time yeah and then the other issue
about memorizing notes or memorizing a
text is tempted temptation to memorize
terms in as opposed to concepts so it's
always important when you've read
something or taken the notes to be able
to elaborate on them to explain why is
this important
what would happen if this weren't true
what how does it relate to what I
already know I guess that's the
difference between pure recall and
comprehension that right yes and and
which leads ultimately into consent
try learning right okay that's
interesting so I did question that I
want you to ask him we've led onto it
pretty perfectly here is it possible to
learn something but not remember it well
sure there's all kinds of things we've
learned that we don't but we can't
recall functionally do I guess there's
two ways I don't recall it yeah yeah
there's a lot of stuff that you've
learned that you can't recall until you
get some kind of a clue you'll see
someone out of your past or you start
talking to someone about past things and
all these memories start flooding back
or you catch a smell that's particularly
were when something happened and the
memories start flooding back so that's
maybe a little different from what
you're asking
no I think I think that's right I think
you I think you correct you what you
what we've fallen back to here is the
cues right right exactly right I had
this problem in 1998 my wife and I spent
a year in Italy and I would go and take
lessons on the language and and the only
non English language I had in me and I
didn't have much of it was four years of
French and so my brain kept presenting
the French whenever I was trying to say
something he's not gonna go down very
well within its own yeah I didn't go
down startled to me well I understood it
better after I wrote this book that I'm
I'm cueing you know a foreign word for
whatever and then I discovered after a
year in the country and getting mildly
able to get by with the language that I
could differentiate between the French
and the Italian on demand but it was
because I got more diverse cues I
suppose yes that's that's that's really
interesting so okay we we've understood
the recall would you is it fair to say
that recall forms the foundation for
learning or that the ability yes okay so
without without the capacity for recall
the learning any learning that you build
on top of that from comprehension to
that what was what was the terminology
that you used in conceptual knowledge
conceptual knowledge right okay so what
when in there here's an interesting
thing that lets take or you can take
hitting a fastball well you don't play
baseball over there but take some kind
of a soccer move or take it you know
driving a stick shift car yeah you get
into a car you're a brand new driver
you got to adjust the seat and adjust
the mirror you got to look here and look
there you got to push in the clutch and
push in the the shifter and let out the
clutch while you're putting on the guys
very complicated set of moves and look
and steer out into the roadway and move
along well you and I do that without any
thought whatsoever
I mean we're thinking about the luncheon
we're about to arrive at yeah so there's
a lot of learning and particular
procedural learning that the recall is
that the procedural learning is kind of
chunked like the scientists actually
call it chunked in a part of the brain
and it's available to us just like that
without having to think no how what do I
do with this shift lever what do I do
with my feet is there and we get to
people who are at very high level in the
sciences for example or any field
musicians whatever they have spent
enough time with the fundamentals of
physics or energy and transfer or
whatever those things are that they just
invoke this law or that law
subconsciously as you're looking at a
situation so those of us who don't have
that knowledge we had to think through
every darn step we had to think through
every part of that shifting and driving
sequence but with practice especially if
it's spaced out it becomes second nature
to us and then we possess it and then
that becomes a mental model that we can
build on in other in connected to other
abilities or other bodies of knowledge I
understand so time and attention that to
a degree is is going to be an important
factor that trying you know cramming and
and rushing you're learning together is
not giving you enough time to allow that
to settle and then to come back to it
right well that's exactly
so it isn't just spacing out the
practice of something with intervals
between so that you're a little rusty so
it's a little more difficult to do and
that difficulty actually strengthens
there's our really difficulties again
right yeah right but it's also true that
in a course if you're let's say your
professor and of course is better to
introduce a lot of the material earlier
in the course and come back to it in
distributed over the period of the
course because when learning is
distributed like that it sticks better
and it has more opportunities to connect
with the other related material instead
of doing it in block fashion or in a
silo okay you know first we're gonna do
this we're gonna do that yeah so you
kind of look you take an overview of the
entire map and then you begin to move
through the map piece by piece right and
so if you're managing your time I know
I'm gonna have a test next Thursday on
such-and-such you don't want to say
Wednesday is my day I'm dedicating to
that you're better off dedicating some a
little a little bit of time each day
between now and then because that
distributing that out over time is going
to help your brain do what it does well
our brains are such that if we go to bed
pondering a challenge or a problem the
brain we've discovered is working at
that through the night and it will throw
out your relevant stuff and try to
connect us to other stuff it's a
remarkable thing so you are kind of
empowering your brain to take some
responsibility for learning this
material if you start it early and come
back to it from time to time instead of
trying to force it force it into your
brain well I'm afraid that now I'm
afraid that eighteen years of full-time
education led me to do everything less
knit so I memorably I'm probably patient
zero for how bad you can be at cramming
but you know I can I can certainly
appreciate the times when I have spent a
little bit more time over stuff and I've
distributed it throughout my week or
however it may be I'm right in thinking
I read a
I read a study recently that talked
about the capacity for problem-solving
before and after a night sleep versus if
you had one 5-hour chunk or two
two-and-a-half hour chunks spread over
two days and the difference between the
group that had the sleep in between and
was their brains were allowed to reset
and look at the problem with fresh eyes
the capacity for them to complete the
problem was so much so much more
impressive than the group that just had
one yeah one go at it for five hours
which two-degree almost sounds
counterintuitive do you think oh I've
got to get back in the same headspace
and I've got to get myself up to speed
again when I start yeah I've got to
recall all this stuff that I did that I
might have forgotten but you know almost
slightly covered intuitively it doesn't
seem to be that way it seems to be that
like you say distributing it is yeah
there's a really interesting study of
medical residents who are learning to
reattach tiny vessels with a surgical
stitch in the way in this country they
do that they go away for a day and
there's four lessons the first they get
a video and then they're given a little
bit of rubber tubing called a Penrose
drain and they're shown how to pass
their stitches through an entire
surgical knots and then they see a video
and they're given some synthetic tissue
and they practice that then they're seen
a video and they get given a turkey
thigh so there's four videos four
sessions one day the end of the day they
are supposedly on top of this this skill
okay so well in this in the study half
the group did it that way there are 38
of them and the other half came in and
did the first video and practice and
they went away for a week and they came
back to second week for the second video
on practice and I'm thinking those those
doctors are sitting there thinking wow
let's see if I can remember what was
that less yeah exactly my life is busy
you know and they struggle to kind of
recall what it was and they had this
next lesson and they went away for a
week so I would like this for weeks so
they had the exact same training but
those whose learning was spaced out over
four weeks far exceeded the others in
all expert measures and they were then
they had a surprise test they were given
a rat that had a severed aorta and their
challenge was to save the rat to
reattach the art and all of those who's
learning was spaced out succeeded in a
large percentage of those whose learning
wasn't spaced out and we're not able to
see if they're lucky if you were right I
want them to do this first goal and then
just a great example of this the simple
power of exposing your brain to
something and working with a little bit
than going away and coming back later
and making that effort to recall and
then adding in okay so we've got we've
got recall we understand the importance
of that moving on to the second the
second key concept that you had which
was desirable difficulties and the
spacing our effort can you explain how
someone can apply that how can you how
can you force desirable difficulties
into a studying practice well let's take
a subject I mean you can you can study
let's say there was a great study of Y
don't worry I'll use one where people
were identifying learning to identify
birds and so they had I don't know four
or five different families of birds and
they were given exemplars of each of the
families so they'd be given a bunch of
Thrasher's to learn and then they'd be
given a bunch of you know I'm not a bird
guy maybe Raptors or whatever the
different groups were okay yeah and and
then and then they were a challenge they
were showing a bird they hadn't studied
and they were challenged to identify
which family belong to and the
interesting thing about birds is within
these families there's no single
characteristic that is true of all birds
within a family so you're looking at a
comp a sort of a
a group of different kinds of
characteristics that generally would
come to define a family okay so those
who learned it in this way looking at
many types of one and many many examples
of another's worth didn't learn them
nearly as well as those who had the
different exemplars shown them in random
order so this is a study if you were
studying you study in random order and
they learned far better they learned
they were better able to identify the
unifying characteristics as well as the
differentiating characteristics of those
birds and in other kinds of same motor
skills learning in the same way of
mixing up the the particular problems
that you're trying to do or the motor
skills movements they become much better
at transferring that skill to an
unfamiliar situation so what if you're
in a study situation where you've got a
group of different types of problems
that you're trying to master you can
take it upon yourself use flashcards to
mix up your expand amaz'd order in a
random way right okay that's interesting
so neurologically there must be
something going on within the brain that
this particular mix-up of recall of
recall requirements that must help to
embed the learning somehow yes
so I'll say that one of the differences
between cognitive psychology and
neuroscience is that the cognitive
psychologists do these empirical studies
if this happens what is the result and
they learned from that the
neuroscientists then are saying well how
does that work in the brain what is
going on in the brain and so those two
fields are coming together but there's a
long way from our really understanding
exactly how this works but I'll give you
a very brief example these were
elementary school children who were
tossing beanbags into baskets okay
and 12 weeks everyday at gym for 12
weeks ladies a boring 12 well they're
pretty young kids they like tossing the
30 bags and if they're easily they're
easily pleased
tossed every time into a four foot
basket the other group toss sometimes
into three foot and sometimes into five
foot never in the forfeit at the end of
12 weeks they're all tested on the
4-foot basket and those who are best
able to hit the 4 foot basket we're the
ones that have practice on three feet
and five feet but never on the four feet
that's so interesting so the reason for
that the speculation
you know what the scientists believe is
the reason for that is that these four
foot the three foot and five foot
challenges required variation in judging
distance and the motor response to it
and gave them more complex that the
really interesting thing for me was it
they believed that this skill of the
three and five foot tossers was encoded
in a different part of the brain where
more complex motor skills are encoded
than those who just repeated the four
foot toss over and over and over again
one was a little more robotic and didn't
require the yep the extra comprehension
right the conceptualization yeah right
that's really interesting that's a
fascinating study so I think what you've
done there is you've touched on what
again is a cognitive bias that we
sometimes have to presume that because
we're able to recall you know if we
stick to one thing for a night and
you're able to recall that one thing
you're like yes I've got some work done
it's planting a flag in the ground that
okay I can remember this one thing
whereas the desirable difficulty which
is potentially a better route to
learning longer term in the short term
can actually make you feel like you're
doing less work right or like you're
making less progress so oh well I can't
really in full recall any of these
individual parts but across the whole
the amount that you've learned
in quotation marks has increased is that
fair to say yes it is I think you do are
more easily discouraged when you do that
is there I just must say in any of these
things that you're gonna try to practice
in a random order you want to try you
know you want to try your 20-foot putt a
few times you kind of get a sense of
what you're trying to do you want to
find the volume of of the spheroid a few
different ones a few times so you get a
sense of what that is and then the
practice is mixed up so don't keep doing
the single one until you've got it
nailed so to speak interrupt it
interrupt it and move on to the others
and come back to it later it won't feel
as good but just going back to my own
personal experience struggling with the
Italian language well you got over there
the first of the year and by the fall of
that year I was with some young Italians
we had befriended from the school and
and we were chatting in Italian and I
heard myself using idioms that I didn't
know I knew and these had come to me
through stopping I rode my bike around a
lot and I'd stop at the town water pumps
to get water and I'd try to chat with
the people who are hunting birds or
whatever you know and there was always a
struggle and a frustration but the brain
is probably for both it probably some
both holidays as well probably a
frustration for them as well as for
years and Americans give too much weight
to your frustration you just need to
kind of trust your brain and then your
brains working at making sense of it as
long as you give it the challenge yeah
okay so I get that sort of touches on
the one of the third main concepts isn't
it as well that too
you don't really know I guess using your
own judgment for how your learning is
going sometimes you kind of just need to
stick to the program right well right a
really important thing that this
these cognitive psychologists talk about
us well they call it metacognition which
is thinking about your thinking and that
is we're easily duped into thinking
we're or on top of something that we've
got it and so what's important is to
test yourself from time to time do you
really have it can you really do it
can you really explain this and so self
testing has a couple of benefits one is
you learn whether your judgement of what
you know and can do actually is accurate
and it and it helps you focus where you
need to bring it up a little bit but the
other is the fact of recalling this
stuff is a great way to strengthen your
retention of your mastery and retention
of us so as as a study strategy as
self-quizzing ism is potent in several
ways there's a kind of goals me go well
I just say when we're talking in schools
with professors and teachers one of the
fundamental things that is highly
effective is for the instructor to
incorporate frequent low stakes quizzing
in the course low stakes so that people
aren't freaked out by no pressure yeah
right you just really dial really dial
down the pressure and have the the
experience and ultimately the habit of
recalling from memory what this stuff is
in the end that if you can do that in a
course where you're reaching back to
earlier material as well as more recent
stuff that stuff gets brought forward
and better connected it's a very potent
and not very difficult a strategy for
helping students get to the middle and
the end of their course on top of the
material that's interesting there's a
program that I know a lot of my friends
who adopt is medical students use called
Anki I'm not sure thank you yes so on
keys cue cards write randomized cue
cards mostly with multiple-choice
questions and would that fit into your
model of
consistent low-level testing yes Anke is
great yeah I wish I wish that I'd known
about Anki while I was at while I was at
university I think it might have made my
my last minute procrastination tactics a
little bit less about Anki and some
other online stuff is it you can have it
you can set it up to to come to your
phone and periodically yeah you did they
get reminders will be side dinner and I
look over to one of the guys and they'll
have his lab is an kikyo cause his
reminders popped up laughs you were in
our household if you were doing anything
other than practicing what he's supposed
to learn he'd get a steep scolding from
my wife right that's a disgust that's an
undesirable difficulty right there okay
so we've got the capacity for recoil
we've got the desirable difficulties and
we've got kind of trying to trying to
ignore what your brain is telling you
about how your learning is going yeah I
think it helps if if you can think about
stuff you struggle with that you've had
these kind of breakthrough moments it
might be I think of people on BMX stunt
bikes I think of people doing video
games trying to find their way to the
next level trying this trying that you
know and oh yeah this is what I did last
time that worked kind of thing all the
different ways that we're not thinking
of as academics but in our lives where
we go through these kinds of space and
episodic exposures to something we're
trying to master and then at some point
you realize it's coming to you you know
you've kind of got it yeah that's going
to be the same with the somatic material
in a class or with the motor skills
stuff when you're trying to learn how to
stitch up a rat or trying to you know I
do I went viral oh oh I saw yeah okay I
understand on that um did you
in the book did you touch on anything to
do with the focused and diffuse mode
networks did you look at did you look at
that much at all I don't think I've
heard of that okay okay so there was
this - so there's a course from Coursera
which is a massive open online course
and it's called learning how to learn
and I had a little bit of a look through
that before I before I knew we were
gonna have our podcast today and with
that they they're focusing a lot on the
focus and diffuse mode networks what
they were talking about there was it
seems to me the longer term the ability
to recall over time and this as you say
this more open mode of thinking as
opposed to a more procedural mode of
thinking that when you're learning
something and you go away and then you
come back you often have a very open
mind to what the what the solutions may
be we've discussed it previously I've
said I did a podcast and meditation not
very long ago with Cory Allen and one of
the one of the things that I wish
wouldn't happen but I also appreciate
does is when I sit down to meditate and
I quieten my thoughts
that's often when I have some of my best
ideas of the day which is terrible
because I'm trapped in this I'm supposed
to be trapped focusing on clearing my
mind and I've got all of these really
good like awesome ideas coming to me and
I think God I just could can you not
happen when I'm not meditating can the
meditating just be allowed to continue
on its own all right yeah I've had that
experience but of course this is the
brain offering you some ideas and I if I
understand this difference between the
focus and diffused I think one of the
one of the astonishing things in writing
is when your mind presents a metaphor
for something that helps make clear the
this other thing you know this notion of
the similarities between things that
your brain recognizes and so
this is one of the things I believe from
what I've read about sleep that begins
to happen when you think about struggle
a little bit with a problem or maybe a
conceptual problem in the evening and in
the night
the brain will kind of look around and
see what do I know that's similar to
this are there models that are like this
others is it like this other thing and
you can get some great breakthrough
ideas that way so maybe in the in the
meditation where you're just giving your
brain you're trying to focus on the
mantra but you're also focusing on your
breathing and your relaxation and it's a
very freeing thing and if the brain is
presenting you with images and ideas you
know I I think I can only think that
that's constructive you know I agree I
couldn't agree more I think one of the
examples that was used was Newton and it
was that he would sit in his chair with
ball bearings in his hand and he would
wait he would wait until he just fell
asleep and the ball bearings would drop
from his hand and crack on the floor and
it would wake him up and that was the
moment at which for him he often had a
lot of breakthroughs and you know if
it's if it's good enough Newton it's
probably good enough for us it happens
for me when I get when I get frustrated
with my writing and I get on the bike
and I head up the hill and I just smell
the smells and look at the horizon and I
bike along and all of a sudden you know
my brain starts giving me ideas I get
this like aha moment this is this is
what what I could do about that problem
is and then I can come back and work on
it do you think it's difficult to ask
someone who is learning or trying to be
productive or writing or whatever it
might be do you think it's difficult to
learn when enough focused time is enough
and it's time to move on to oh it's time
to take as you say like a planned break
to give yourself that room to breathe
because you know you need to spend some
time and attention exposed to the
material or exposed to the particular
physical practice or whatever
might be but then also you need this
time away from it as well do you think
it can be a difficult scheduling problem
for people to know when enough is enough
well I'm sure it can be I don't know I
don't know of research into that
question my own human nature tells me
you need to have you need to mix it up
and you need to get out of your chair or
get out and get some exercise and then
come back to it but I don't know I'm not
aware of research on it one of the
things that was a pleasant surprise for
me when I was working on this book I
hadn't been aware of the search tool
Google Scholar where you can search for
published research on you know you can
put in a term and see where research has
been done and thumb through the
different published studies yeah yeah
that's kind of useful I suppose most
everybody else knows about it but I
didn't and I found it very awful but I
you know it to me intuitively yeah but
of course I'm saying intuition leads us
astray with learnings so you gotta be
careful on both sides of the fence right
yeah well there's one thing you know one
of the things about being a
non-scientist writing this book with two
scientists was I was I tried to be I
tried to take liberties in relating the
science to stories of real people and
incidents in their lives and so forth
and drawing parallels but stay within
the strict limits of what the empirical
research shows us and what and where
we're drifting in a speculation to say
this is speculation but it might be
because of such and such yeah so we've
gone through the the three key concepts
that you've got there the capacity for
recall the desirable difficulties and
then ignoring me ignoring the cognitive
biases to to one degree or another or
cutting yourself some slack if it feels
difficult thinking you're not getting it
yeah cut yourself some slack you think
you're not getting it but you probably
are
yeah okay um so other any other elements
that you think that people need to be
able to understand when it comes to
learning is there anything that we
haven't gone through yet
well there is this theory of a growth
mindset that has been introduced by
cognitive psychologists Stanford
University in California named Carol
Dweck and she's done some work that she
or she studied with she she got she
would took an interest in why do some
people become helpless when faced with a
difficult problem and so she did some
work with some low performing New York
middle school junior high school
students and gave them a little seminar
on how the brain works and then half the
students
she took aside and talked about memory
the other half she took aside and said a
lot of people think that their abilities
are set at birth by the gift of their
genes but in fact when you work hard to
learn something you are building new
connections in the brain and over time
your actual increasing your intellectual
abilities through these challenges these
mental challenges she sent them all back
into class she didn't tell the teachers
about these two different subgroups and
the students who had been taught that
they have some influence or other
intellectual abilities by picking
tougher problems and persisting at them
began out performing the other students
and she dr. Dweck developed this sort of
duality of a fixed mindset versus a
growth mindset that people with a fixed
mindset tend not to pick problems they
won't do well at because it'll indict
their sense of their native ability or
as those who have a growth mindset when
they encounter a difficult problem try a
little hard or try a different way you
know carry on forward and do better now
so there's an issue here I think when
we're saying that some difficulties are
desirable it's not doesn't sound like
good news to students a lot of students
want the easiest path possible right I
mean we all do we're all we all did yeah
we all want to get as much as possible
for as little as possible right it's in
nature
I think we all agree on that so I think
I think that there's more research that
needs to be done about whether a belief
in an understanding of this ability to
improve your brain is actually a
motivator for people but the fact
remains nonetheless that when you learn
new things especially you you rise up
the complexity of the topic you're
dealing with you are increasing your
intellectual ability and there's that
many more things that you now have the
ability to learn because you have places
to attach them you can't learn something
new or if you don't have something to
attach it to that you already know so I
think there's the field of motivation is
one where there's some interesting work
being done and it's one that I think it
helps for people to keep in mind that
you need to you need to be a kind of a
coach to your own brain saying I know
this doesn't feel too good but guess
what it's really gonna pay off yeah I
totally get that is it a weird a weird
analogy that I can draw between this and
a recent podcast that I did with some
CrossFit coaches from the UK and in it I
was asking about mental toughness in
sport and I was talking to them about
how they prepare for these competitions
and during these CrossFit competitions a
lot of the athletes very very heavily
mediated by their capacity to suffer
discomfort and again with that it's a
lot to do with mental state so I was
asking the guys you know how do they
prepare in an appropriate way and what
they said was how many events is it over
a weekend is it seven events over a
weekend
okay well during you prep for it do 20
do 20 events over a weekend and then
when you get there you realize I've
prepared so much further above and
beyond where I needed to to bring it
back to you know you're right the
difference between an athlete that's
doing that and typically how someone
will be learning even if they're being
taught by a lecturer or a teacher on a
formal course at university or whatever
it might be the coach is mediating that
impression of how the training is going
right it's very rare I don't think I
ever once spoke to a lecturer at
university or spoke to my tutor and said
my learning is going slowly I just
perceived that as a byproduct of our
world like learning isn't easy and I
need to just help put get my head in the
book a little bit more until it sticks
and right I think that the the paradigm
the environment that students exist in
it's very different to that typically if
someone patata perhaps who's doing sport
that you know your coach can see when
you are and when you're not getting it
whereas yes there's a lot more a lot
more variables that can well does your
lecturer think that your test scores
during the build-up to exams are low
because you're not working hard enough
they don't really know they don't see
you practice do you know I mean and the
practice is a lot less visual as well
it's a lot less easy for them to work
out so yeah I think the the concept of
desirable difficulties is it's something
that shy of definition as as we've done
today is probably gonna be really hard
for people to actually work out where
it's right yes I don't think it it has
to be real hard I have a couple thoughts
one is that we're encouraging teachers
to help students construct their own
understanding of the material as opposed
to lecturing here's what the material is
in trying to impart the lecturers
understanding so that means the
classrooms become much more involved in
exercises that engage the students and
working through and figuring stuff out
and so that's one thought
I've lost the other ones oh did you end
up with your comment I said it was about
it was about CrossFit and it was about
having a high level of difficulty than
you need so you can go off train hard
train hard perform easy right yeah I
think I don't know it's gone sorry um
but no I I think you're totally right I
can definitely say
you know I enjoyed my time at Newcastle
University but the course that I was
doing quite often we'd have 200 to 250
people in a lecture theatre and that was
for a lot of the a lot of the modules
that I took and in terms of
comprehension and that two-way
communication with the person who is
disseminating the course information
it was non-existent like you can't you
can't ask us around the room of 200
people
you can bet I mean they could barely
barely keep us awake because it's such a
big room now so unengaging it so on and
so forth so yeah the the implications
for teachers here are almost as wide as
the implications are for students right
right I think that's right and I think
the the revelation for the teacher is
it's really about learning it's not
about teaching this is about learning
this is about how you can help students
become the learners not you be the
teacher and the the oh this other
thought came and now it's gone back
again it's just making me yeah I don't
know it's all this it's all this talk
it's all this talk of recall it's
ruining your capacity for recall I think
my short-term memory is that status my
working memory it's just a little fried
right now right well that's fun that's
totally fine
maybe you should go away maybe need to
go away and come back to it probably
need to do that I think we'd laid out
some some quite nice concepts there
we've gone through what does learning
mean how do learning and memory relate
what does recall mean the desirable
difficulties and giving yourself a
little bit of a break and and not I
think I liked it the the third key
concept that you've got there because I
think that's the one which will mediate
all of the rest that if you don't
believe that you're making progress
you're you're going to fall back into
the typical brute force one concept at a
time approach and I think that the all
of the others are relying on you having
faith in the learning process working
right so I got my idea back so I would
have yeah
I have two thoughts one one is that
often an instructor what instructor is
teaching you about a topic the
information is arbitrary the student
doesn't know why it's important or what
it connects to and so forth it's really
important for instructors to when they
lay out something new say to explain
here's how this relates to where we've
been and where we're going here's how it
connects to what we already know oh so
that the students have a way of
connecting to it and grabbing hold of it
okay and making sense you know the other
side of that is I think students have an
opportunity if they're not getting it -
to say to the instructor I'm not getting
it I don't quite understand how this
relates could you give me an example of
how this is true elsewhere or in another
topic or something to help me understand
it okay and then I can practice at you
know building that learning dialogue I
think is we just used to a kind of I'm
the expert you're the student I'm gonna
tell you how it is you're gonna take
notes then we're gonna have a test yeah
that's definitely my functional
[Music]
experience of learning that is it's very
much a one-way street and that there
will be it almost felt sometimes like
lecturers knew that they had to ask a
particular number of questions and that
that was just a hurdle they had to
overcome the same as saying the next
slide it wasn't something which was
being done to actually embed the
learning right yeah which I think that's
really interesting are the implications
for the teachers and lecturers I mean
you know in an ideal world every
University course would probably start
with two weeks on learning how to learn
right no I think every incoming student
at a university should have of course in
that how learning works and how to
manage your time and you know I was in
Florida International University of
Miami where they read make a stick and
sat down at the law school and they've
completely restructured their
orientation and their management
students through the two-year law school
all day around these principles they've
gone from typically fourth or fifth
place in the bar exam in Florida as
escort to placing first place if I have
out of the last six exams but it's by
this conscious effort is when the
students come in let's talk about these
principles and how they work and having
experience with it what I just was
having correspondence with someone in
Ecuador who was saying I would like to
have a simple classroom experience and
my co-author Mart McDaniel said well
they were there learning vocabulary
he said well here's what you could do
you could give them half the vocabulary
and a sheet to memorize and you could
give them the other half of the
vocabulary flashcards to learn and then
have a test and see for themselves which
ones they learn better yeah yeah yeah
and now you know I think that getting
students to buy into the process is is
super super important that you're right
that there's more difficulty going to be
through this particular style of
learning it's going to feel less
immediately gratifying right because you
can't straightaway recall big chunks of
concepts and you need to have faith you
need to trust the process it's what we
say about when when we talk to power
lifting coaches and stuff like that and
some of the athletes aren't happy with
where the lifts are at and they don't
feel right and they said look just trust
the process have faith in the fact that
you have out sourced the specific task
of programming what is to be done and
when to someone who knows what they're
talking about and it is your job to do
what they say or they tell you to do and
not vice versa you shouldn't be
questioning it obviously there needs to
be a back-and-forth as you've said when
you know you need two regular points
reassess where your where your learning
is that and how you're learning is
progressing but stick to the program I
think right not only stick to the
program but I think have two goals 1
goal is to master the content or the
skill the other is to learn how to be a
superior learner so that when you get
out of whatever this program is
and you find something else you want to
do you know you have the habits that
will make you a highly effective at
mastering that and that will make you a
competitor out in this crazy world give
you a great advantage for sure I mean
it's a principle that's completely as
we've said at the start it's ubiquitous
right if you can if you can learn well
then it's the the first domino has
fallen on even a single everything and
that goes from as you've you know you've
used a wide range from physical pursuits
to intellectual pursuits as specialists
you know it's it's definitely definitely
something very crucial I think you know
I I wish that I'd had a better
comprehension of time management when I
was at university and of how learning
works and of the strategies that I could
have implemented I think had I have had
that it would have made my life a lot
easier I by look managed to fall on at
least one of the three key concepts that
you have put in here and I genuinely
think that's probably the majority of
what's carried me through carried me
through my university degree so you know
it's it's fortunate that I stumbled upon
that kind of just through trial and
error but if people can implement all of
these I think they'll they'll have a
much easier and much much more
comprehensive learning experience well I
hope that some of your listeners tumbled
to it and give it a shot I'm sure that
they will so can make it stick make it
stick indeed can you tell the listeners
where they can find you online
well there's a website make it stick
comm all one word make it stick yep the
book is make it stick the science of
successful learning is published by
Harvard University Press it's available
on Amazon it's being translated into 14
different languages so if you have
listeners who will prefer to read it in
a language other than English some of
those are already out and others will be
out soon so some of your Italian friends
can make them learn English yeah that's
it that's it yeah exactly
that's fantastic Peter I'll make sure
that links to the book and
to your website we'll be in the show
notes below so if anyone does want to
get hold of the book and highly
recommend it and they can grab that
through the show notes in the links I'm
sure that we're going to become
inundated with some questions and stuff
like that so if we do have something
I'll fly them over to you and I'll be
able to answer those on future episodes
as well but I really appreciate your
time
I think I appreciate yours Chris yeah
it's really been fun sharing with you
it's been fantastic I really do think
that would have helped some people in
reframe their their approach to learning
the we keep coming back to it but I do
think that you can't emphasize it enough
that the capacity your understanding of
how to learn is the fundamental case of
what is going to restrict your ability
to learn anything like it's happened and
I think it I think it's a really
fundamental task and hopefully as well
over the coming years as you say
universities and institutions have
started to latch on to the idea that
this is important and I know if you can
continue singing that song then maybe
maybe University won't be quite such a
daunting and difficult task for some
people in the future as well I think the
window be at your back if you do that's
the plan well Peter thank you very much
again and I agree thank you very much
yes hey thank you very much
[Music]